when you're a front man for a band and
you look at some guys like mick jagger's
approach like
he dances james brown danced i wouldn't
call you a guy who
dances i'm fascinated with frontman like
i always thought when you would be
climbing
when you would be climbing up on rafters
and risking your life
and and like doing crazy stuff i said
eddie does that
because he doesn't dance and he's got to
hold the audience's attention
so this was my theory on you you know i
was i went
i loved music i loved live music and i
would
work for free for some you know so i
would hump gear during the day
so i could uh get into the show you know
i could see five shows in a week you
know because i didn't have to pay i just
show up at four hump some gear during
those times you know i'd be at the
at the metro in chicago where i'd be at
a uh
you know you'd be in one of those
theaters that had kind of an ornate
you know in in the the king and queen
boos on either side
and curtains and all that stuff and
while i'm waiting for the next you know
waiting for the band
in between waiting and waiting i used to
look at that stuff and go like
man it would be fun to climb that
curtain and then jump into that red
velvet king and queen booth and then you
could
get to the middle and then you could
hang off that light thing
do a little monkey bars and then flip
into the crowd
right near where the sound board is like
that was just came from me being bored
in between shows giving myself like a
mental exercise i don't know
i never thought i'd ever have the
opportunity to do it
but whenever the opportunity came i was
like you didn't
i've been waiting when i would see you
climbing and really like like almost
like a guy without a net like a like in
a circus or something
i'd say wow this is unfucking believable
and i was thinking like
do you never worried about being
paralyzed or like falling on your head
and then it would all be over i mean i
was like this guy's got too good a life
to be doing that but you didn't see it
that way
well we were 24 25
the music was like you know
the music was powerful and you know what
it was
always i don't think i ever did any of
that you know
kind of crazy evil knievel shenanigans
except for during one song which was
called porch and
and the whole thing about that song was
celebrating like you know this we are
alive for
one time you know anything could happen
at any moment
like you know the ice cream truck could
hit you tomorrow
you know you have you know that was the
whole idea of it let's all
you know i think so much of our music or
our songs
is like let's let's you know live in the
moment you know
right and so that was my version
of you know that was my extra curricular
expressing the meaning of the song i
mean it's amazing that
you know it really did work out pretty
much every time